TYRION LANNISTER: Look at me
and tell me what you see.
What you see is a dwarf.
If I'd been born a peasant,
they might have left me
out in the woods to die.
Alas, I was born
a Lannister of Casterly Rock.
Things are expected of me.
I'm Dr. Ali Mattu,
cognitive behavioral therapist,
and I'm here today
in collaboration with HBO
to offer my take
on themes of mental health
in their shows.
Never forget what you are,
the rest of the world will not.
Wear it like armor,
and it can never be used
to hurt you.
Today, we're focusing on
depression through the lens
of Tyrion Lannister
in Game of Thrones.
♪ (MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
Anhedonia is a core symptom
of depression,
and it's what happens when you
no longer experience joy
or pleasure in the things
that usually gave you
joy or pleasure.
It zaps any motivation you have.
You seem rather drunk.
Drinking and lust.
No man can match me
in these things.
(GRUNTS)
Usually the first thing
people do
when they might be experiencing
anhedonia,
is just to try more of the kind
of stuff that they enjoy,
to try to feel something.
But that usually doesn't work.
What you need is to use
that anhedonia,
and try to understand
what changes you might need
to make in your life
to get you moving
in the direction
that you want to be in.
I'd given up on life,
until Varys convinced me
you might be worth living for.
You chop off my head, well,
my final days were interesting.
You're going to advise me.
What I like to ask my patients
is,
to imagine your 100th birthday.
Who's there?
What stories are they sharing
about your relationship?
About the achievements
that you've made in your life?
What I love about Tyrion is
his story's about
connecting with
a larger purpose,
doing what's best for Westeros.
Owning who he is...
(CHEERING)
...and the unique ways
he can help others.
We'll never know if Tyrion
was struggling
with a mental illness.
But whatever
he was dealing with,
didn't get in the way
of him being a hero.
And that's true for all of us.
No matter what
you're experiencing,
it doesn't have to get
in the way
of living the life you want
to live.
That's my take for the day,
I'm Dr. Mattu.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪